vous à donner un chiffre mais oui sinon
mes blocs comment est ce que vous pouvez
dire si je sais pas j'ai pas vu le
sondage s'est pas dit la face vous voyez
rien ce serait loyal et franc
encore une fois on n'avait pas trouvé un
onze voire 100 % des lycéens qu'ils
soient hyper inquiète un qui soit
tournée oui on est là pour on est là
pour écouter on peut aux consignes et du
coup c'est un mensonge et et nous on
fera de gadgets ou est-ce que l'on peut
encore changer pour changer
mais oui mais oui mais alors qu'ils
tournent abalo mise sur son portable on
va barricader
mais bon ça m'étonnerait donc ça peut
bouger ça va pas être remis en cause
intégra renommée peut y avoir des
aménagements oui bonsoir monsieur le
ministre
oui bonsoir c'est monsieur hanouna cyril
on est en direct sur touche pas à mon
poste
j'espère que me regarde à défaut d'être
ici ah bah merci oui il est sympa oui
alors on a le ministre au téléphone jean
michel blanquer
on est avec anne christine langue qui
vous a défendu bec et ongles sur le
plateau je vous le dis voilà boyer qui
saigne travers bombardements oui
monsieur le ministre juste on est avec
des élèves et cette histoire de contrôle
continu ccc pour eux c'est un crève
coeur
enfin il vole le contrôle continu et
veulent pas d'examen en présentiel est
ce que vous allez faire quelque chose ou
pas oui je suis d'accord soit des
organisations lycéennes qui sont on sait
d'ailleurs que l'éducation qu'on parlait
de ça n'est qu'un pis aller sur le cac
alors savait pas trop générales oui je
touche au delà pour sa lancée et puis en
plus on parle aussi d or contrat on
parle des bts aussi originaux
fessionnels et les deux épreuves en
compte par écrit mais c'est sur
l'inconscient
certains élèves n'ont pas pu faire bah
oui c'est ça un aménagement est ce qu
est ce que ça peut bouger monsieur le
ministre
est ce que ça peut bouger
on va travailler on a une réponse demain
à cette semaine c'est encore des
aménagements mais pas d'accord et ça va
c'est donc ce n'est pas figé
c'est au sujet des épreuves terminales
es très haut même marche on a transformé
en contre continue non mais pas par moi
c'est comme ça qui a déjà 80% contre on
peut ainsi pas pour leur rencontre à
dakar il pas fait pas prier et à
l'histoire du hors contrat aussi ça
c'est encore un taux de succès parce que
[Musique]
l'année dernière vous l'avez fait pour
cent de réussite
non non non je sois sérieuse non mais
c'était normal que vous allez on vous
tue c'est pas vrai ce serait beaucoup
plus inscrit auprès de tout le monde
pour tous les cycles est juste la spla 1
ce qui est important c'est justement de
voir l'intérêt et élèves l'intérêt des
hells et crémants dessert réussi pour ça
il faut que les épreuves qu'ils soient
tus serait faisable
c'est pourquoi par exemple mais aucune
sortie d'abidjan les parties programme
en caissettes les partis ont traité
cette alliance qui choqua interrogé sur
des impasses et ça c'est le genre de
chose peut le faire mais c'est un drôle
de zozo fillon va regarder aussi vichy
d'avoir conspiré pour monsieur le
ministre monsieur me dis donc c'est pas
figé ça peut encore bouger ça peut
encore bouger réussit donc ça va bouger
lacoste on nous engueule de laclos
payante pour les joueurs convoqués
demain on aura des nouvelles on vient
ici débattre demain demain on aura des
nouvelles même temps leur contrat mais
ça nous aurait coûté tout le monde sait
ont donné dans une ambiance rites et non
des moments comme ça
merci monsieur blanc kg soit vous
viendrez sur le bateau tout cas j'ai on
était un petit peu dur avec vous la
mission merci d'avoir répondu 4h mans
merci on s'en excuse mais on espère
qu'on aura réussi peu tous
on espère qu'on aura des bonnes
nouvelles voilà et on espère qu'on aura
de nouvelles demain et on avait voilà on
essaie des choses et on espère que de
nouvelles demain et merci à rambo ce
soir sur ces 8
11 mars merci merci merci à voir